should only be cheering for people
there's no time for Envy there's no time
for jealousy there's no time for
gossiping at dinner tearing down
somebody that's winning I'm shooting for
[__] in my own industry other Ad
Agency if they're good enough they're
good enough I'm cheering for people
because nobody's taking a penny or a
smile out of my pocket I live this life
where I really cheer for others even my
competitors I swear it's in my soul I
got that for my mom cheering for them
let them do their thing has nothing to
do with me the world is abundant nobody
on Earth is taking your money or your
happiness your perception that they are
is taking your money and your [__]
happiness I don't want to lose to my
competitors but I respect my competitors
in my businesses if they're able to
accomplish in our game and I admire it
and I cheer for it I don't think
anyone's success is taking happiness out
of my pocket money out of my pocket
growth out of my pocket the world is
abundant